deswegen sind die und scheiß auf soziale
probleme oder sowie am sind die spiele
genau die es noch das wort verbieten
hallöchen und da sind wir wieder zurück
bei der today show diesmal nur mit denen
und wir wollen und ob gerade weg ist
aber der strom weg in die trainings
publica da vorne ist irgendwo irgendwie
rechen oder so nah für all das hatte die
ganze welt hier zerstört hat ist das bin
ich
wir haben schon gesucht
und leider einige für eine römische bad
ob sie es auch auf meinen flug aber hier
sieht auch so aus wie ein fan feier
vulkan des tempels tanztempel aber nicht
weg auch wenn das was wird dann das ist
nicht so mit einer spitzhacke kann man
mal eben so runterlaufen irgendwie zum
beispiel noch gefallen also aber luca du
kannst mir mal verraten was für einen
zug tipp du dir zugtyp du dir diesmal
als vorbereiter ausgesucht hast wo
wählbaren bauen
die tukker monster durch die gegend
somit 5 km h da stehst du dann teilweise
mit dem auto eigentlich wird alles zu
ein komisches buch hier
es ist geil da stehst dann teilweise
ditto kann daher und steht habe ich 20
minuten an sonnen verfestigt den top 20
minuten was sonst minuten an diesem
komischen bahnübergang und wartet bis
diese komische tuff tuff banner
hergefallen sind nun musste er stehen
weil du kannst nicht aber so rüber
fahren wo alles einfach so schrecklich
und so ein ding bei euch los nein ich
hoffe mal gut aussehen und nicht dass
die immer wieder ganze noch meckern ist
was er sonst eh schon die ganzen machen
ist oberstdorf ich hasse dich dorf dorf
dorf schlecht schlecht oder wird alle
zuschauer ich kriege schon die schranken
die kommentare das thema wirklich alles
zu allem negative einstellung hat ja
total
du bist ein sehr netter typ denen bin
ich bin immer konstruktiv konstrukt
konstruktion ist das denn
ja das wort sagt mir was letztlich in
dem zusammenhang ich sagen ist scheiße
und
fick dich alle fertig sondern im bereich
intellektuell konstruktiv er das ist uns
irgendwie hier weiterhilft deine meinung
das tut sehr groß sagt dass es eben
nicht so ist sondern dass wir eine
vielleicht eine andere meinung habe und
dem nicht immer einfach zu stimme aber
nicht so neindorf neindorf neindorf
neindorf darum und zu netzwerken wir
wollen negativ wurde aber in bezug auf
das ist auch jeder zurecht zurecht
das habe eigentlich beim thema jetzt da
wir immer wieder neues thema mit ca
schauen wir mal was mit den herren der
aufruf zu spät zur spiele verbrennung
nach dem newton massaker von fabian
steckt also der sprecher
meine alle alle für einen abonnenten
gucken mich gefreut so wie mir das ganze
volk kommt weil er das thema mit den
gezeiten behandelt ich hatte was
allerdings woher hast du das glas wird
sich jetzt von mir geklaut nee ich hab
selber gemacht
kaputt gemacht habe mir den strand bitte
jetzt habe keinen stand mehr 11 bringt
auch so viel es macht haltbarkeit oder
effizienz 1 es reicht auf fünf ist genau
dasselbe
ich mache ich auch nicht groß aber auf
eins ist eigentlich entwurf 15 30 ich
glaube wir brauchen unbedingt mehr kühe
ich hab schon wieder eine zweite hierhin
geholt aber das reichte nicht weil wir
brauchen damit damit in short muss ich
ja wohl erstmal level 30 haben und dass
ich immer aus firmen und reiche aktion
15 uhr ich habe mehr als 15 wieso
bekommen zwanziger machte dafür zwei
feldern echt sagt mir dass mein mann
dann bestimmt 1000 meinen kommentaren so
recht zu recht zurecht mal nein das ist
die dritte das drittletzte solange ja
deswegen wir sind total spät an gewicht
es kommt mir das heute sofort gar nicht
dafür
hausschwein oder so was ist das thema zu
reden
ach ja wir hatten das neutron
wasserkrise den den amoklauf an der
wenig total bescheuert weil immer gesagt
wird ja die spielen amokläufer spiele
und die sind ballerspiele und ja
deswegen sind die und scheiß auf soziale
probleme oder sowie am sind die spiele
genau die essen auf das wort verbieten
ist eine anlehnung an
bücherverbrennungen der selber eins der
lächerlichsten sachen gemeinsam machen
kann also wie in der nazizeit dann
einfach mal alle alle guten deutschen
dichter und denker einfach mal alles
verbrennen damit alles schlecht ist und
noch nazi kultur lesen dürfen können und
dann einfach mal alles verbrennen
mittelalter verbrennen einfach alle
hexen aber jedenfalls befehl noch 4 grad
ab ich hab grad ich finde eigentlich
total
jetzt ist einfach nur total bescheuert
ich frage mich was sie sich dabei
gedacht haben als ob das jetzt
irgendetwas daran verändert sage ich mal
dass es weniger amokläufer gibt bzw
weniger gewalttaten wenn es weniger
ballerspiele gibt ich meine es sind
bestimmt nicht die spiele die leute dazu
die spieler die die leute dazu bewegen
solche taten auszuführen da sind gibt es
sowas von viele hintergründe und die die
die die regierung die redet sich das
immer schön so von wegen ja die spieler
sind schuld wir müssen die spiele
verbieten
das finde ich ein bisschen bescheuert
ist halt ein leichtes opfer weil viele
denken er diese diese computerspiele was
nicht gar nichts mit anfangen was sollen
das und das als die spiele die spieler
lobby und die spiele lobby ist halt doch
deutlich kleiner als zum beispiel die
waffenlobby ihren us an unglaublichen
einfluss hat und wenn mit ihrer visa in
jedem supermarkt eine waffe und dann
wollen alle die spielerkabinen also wat
ich habe jetzt lakers blake also das war
meine meinung ist hier wieder online
meinung den attraktiver da sah ich noch
nie gelesen
übrigens habe ich kenne level 30 server
solcher zaubern
meine einen pickel ein motor was halten
sie von zum thema
ich finde videospiele sollten verbrannt
werden dass das schädigt unsere jugend
unsere kinder werden überhaupt schon
öffentlich ist oft dorffest und dann da
laufen da alle hin und werfen die
spieler da draußen dann freuen sich alle
sie den satan verkauft haben auch sein
assistent aldi geht lagerfeuer und damit
zu einer zeremonie schmeißer all ihre
spieler darauf ein blauer dampf dann
spricht gott zu gehen dass nun alles
besser wird und dann in den tod also
bescheuert bescheuert bescheuert wenn es
heute wieder krass unproduktive ich gehe
gar nicht er wollte noch in die never
oder nicht war ich doch schon ich habe
schon alle mit papis über keine die
amtmann ich habe place trotz war ich
habe 46 kloster fast eine minute meiner
kiste und frage mich immer was ich jetzt
machen wollte
du kannst doch bestimmt gleich mal die
messe festung zeigen euch braucht netter
züge ja das will ich laufe nur einmal
runter in den keller
was hinterher
hey lass mich ja voll angst vor dir
hören sie bloß auf was willst du hier
nur einmal mich umschauen ich würde mich
nicht töten habe 31 level das will
niemand sehen wir jetzt wird ist zu tun
wenn die diamant sowie typisch mann
wenn ich verlasse mich am herzen wie
meinst du nur das ja nicht stören soll
ich ja gibt mir die diamanten zurück den
man retweetet mich gleich noch etwas auf
einer kiste nehme ja es hätte schulter
passt darauf man muss erstmal kriegen
damit man es lernen
ja ich liebe bleibt bestimmt nicht
stehen wenn du hinter mir her bistum
mich schlägt ich bin mit einem
schlagschuss stehen bleiben ich schlage
nicht weg bin ich sofort tot
du ich schlage dich nicht öffentlich
diamanten geben sicher ich will dich
ganz einfach den sie mir oder ich will
dich lass mich erst mal essen lasst mich
jetzt dass wir doch einfach
gib mir doch die diamanten 1 punkten
lena ohne wird wendet an mir vorbei bist
und in einem haus bis unternimmt die
diamanten einfach mit dann will ich dich
also erstmal sind als der mann nicht die
diamanten die fantasien
sie sind von tt wo sind die denn deiner
rüstungen sind dass das jetzt hier die
diamanten von tt ja keine ahnung dann
gibt's dann aber ab
aber was bringt es mir wenn ich ein habe
ich brauche nur zwei um ein schwer zu
verzaubern und bringt es mir doch nicht
verzogen
prof willst du dir machen gesperrt um
das zu verzaubern
um dann damit kommt mir ein update haben
wir die weil ich habe die phoenix bisher
benutzt
für was wo hast du denn die diamanten
dursun schwert ich habe doch selber auch
schon diamanten gefunden man da hin wo
soll ich dir das raussuchen in der
aufgabe aber auf jeden fall sind hier
bin ich von dir gewesen ihr die
diamanten nämlich gefunden
nein die der apothekenkunden nein ich
bin im urlaub sucht jetzt handeln findet
welche denner gib mir einen diamanten
dann teilen wir sonst töte ich dich
jetzt ganz einfach ich hab jetzt tausend
mal gesagt ich mach das wie viele wie
viele zwei das kannst du dir auch in der
aufnahme ankucken 23 man tt hat mehr als
zwei diamanten airbus der rest ja keine
ahnung in seiner kiste
am anfang hat alle daten geklaut
da war nur zwei mal und bei anderen
sachen habe ich von mir genommen
die diamanten war ich selbst auch schon
welche gefunden habe hat jemand
vielleicht schon werkzeuge macht den sie
auch genommen hast bleiben
sondern wohin man hat für werkzeuge was
laberst du vielleicht hat er ja nur
werden tag gehabt
jetzt gibt mir einen die erhalten jedes
mail hüte dich ich sage es jetzt nur
einmal gibt mir einen diamanten genau
jetzt geh nicht weiter gibt nur einen
diamanten oder ich hörte dich lena ich
hätte dich dass du kommst du bekommst du
nicht wenn du mich einmal schlägt dann
bekommst du nicht mehr junge ich habe 31
leveln mich jetzt ist das natürlich wäre
ich hab mir den diamant genau erinnere
mich noch einmal extra generell sind wir
genau zahlen und ich schlage dich nicht
gibt mir ihn genau jetzt dass ich in
ruhe
ich bin ein tot das hat er richtig
verdient er kommt der eiskalte meer an
mein die ganze zeit als gutes vorbild
voranzugehen fragt auch wenn du was
willst du mir diamanten ja weiß aber
nicht ein diamant weiter wieder
sozusagen nicht geklaut töten töten ihr
ja ich kann schreiben
wie macht man noch mal einer truhe
was macht ihr da man gar nichts
natürlich beide höher auf ich gehe raus
nicht angreifen das ist so gewollt
vorher ja warum war das fast freundlich
jetzt eigentlich also ich hab den
diamanten abgegeben ich verstehe nicht
was jetzt auf einmal hat für meine
sachen graphics media ich geb dir bist
unsichtbar da was ich habe gefordert
hatte ich brauche nur ein paar steine
kommen hier sehe ich ja nicht mal so
erzähle ich dich nicht du kriegst deine
sachen die gegen oben
das sind meine sachen die das war ein
komplettes inventar was ich wohl eine
rein getan aber ich dachte ihr tötet
mich
wieso hat wein rock pop shop in seine
wunderkiste in die mitte pyramide getan
also jetzt mal hab ich habe andere
sachen von den halmen so nennen wir das
erstmal werkzeug hätte ich vorher hast
du eine verzauberte eine schaufel bitte
die asse von mir geklaut so raus aus
meinem haus traum bald aus ach so
hermann damit euch für den shopping
paypal verwendet auch wirklich denen das
begreifst du jetzt du hast davor nicht
gewusst ich habe gesagt die haben wir
für was anderes genommen und das waren
ja für was anderes aus dem nichts
sondern
ich vergesse
die
schick
folgendes zu ende 16 minuten
süße bis zum nächsten mal